okay this story is one of those stories
where you really have to look at the
details to know
what what is the story is this a big
story or not
the the story is that democratic vice
presidential nominee kamala harris
has now confirmed that if she and joe
biden are elected
that they would decriminalize the use
of marijuana at the federal level now
everybody went crazy for different
reasons
kamala harris outlined at an event
through facebook live with abc
the broad strokes of the proposal and it
includes
among other things which i will get to
full federal
decriminalization of the use of
marijuana
you had some people on the right who are
just furious who say
decriminalizing marijuana use is the
first step to anarchy
it's the first step to rampant out of
control addiction and chaos everywhere
biden must be stopped
and then you have people on the left who
are saying this is so lame
this is so centrist decriminalized use
we must legalize use we must
decriminalize small-scale dealing of
marijuana
this is way too right-wing for me so
what's the truth
the truth is one that most people don't
want to accept
which is progress typically comes in
steps i believe
we need full legalization of use
regulate it
tax it selling it on the street becomes
sort of like selling illegal cigarettes
and you deal with it like a health issue
instead of a criminal issue when you
have substance abuse
issues without question though
a federal decriminalization would be a
big deal
but it would just be one step with
another four years of trump
we get nothing we just get nothing
simply nothing period
now there are also people mad that
kamala flip-flopped kamala used to be
against legalization and
decriminalization
10 years ago well she's changed her view
and we should applaud that
in other words there are lots of elected
officials who eventually came around
to better positions and they shouldn't
be shamed for that some what some people
call flip-flopping
sometimes is flip-flopping merely for
for sort of political posturing purposes
but sometimes you evolve because you
actually get more information or you
mature
or you come around to the right point of
view so
in 2019 she sponsored legislation which
would federally deschedule
cannabis uh that would would be a great
thing to do
and uh overall we should be glad that
she changed her mind
now let's be real there's a major gap
between decriminalization and
legalization if you legalize cannabis
you can regulate it similar to alcohol
and tobacco
you can tax it to decriminalize
cannabis merely removes criminal
sanctions
when you offend or break the law
cannabis could remain illegal possession
above a certain amount could result in
civil fines or drug education or
treatment
instead of criminal prosecution so it is
not a panacea it is not the
end point but it is a step forward joe
biden
by the way wouldn't just federally
federally decriminalize but according to
his website would
also expunge prior cannabis use
convictions
that's a good thing that gets a bunch of
people cleared
it's certainly not going to impact
low-level dealers who are sitting in
prison and we need to deal with that
but it is a step forward joe biden also
supports
the legalization of medical cannabis at
the federal level
but again would leave decisions about
adult
recreational use up to the states
so listen um this is one of those times
where we we just have to be very real
and pragmatic
if biden gets to do what is on his
platform
it would be the most progressive federal
cannabis policy in the history of a
sitting president period
i get that we want to do more i get that
many of us feel that it's 2020
and this is not enough and we need to be
catching up to other countries that have
dealt with this
uh uh in in more progressive ways
already but
if biden gets in and he does this stuff
the us would be as progressive at as it
has ever been
when it comes to the regulation of
cannabis
if they do this it will lead
to more legalization in more states for
sure
there will be states who if they see
decriminalized federally
expunging convictions so on and so forth
there will be states that maybe right
now or 53 to 47
against legalization that will say look
at look what's happening federally
let's do it you know other states have
done it massachusetts did it colorado et
cetera
this will be a major step forward and of
course we want more but let's not miss
the forest for the trees and much like
with healthcare
is biden's idea perfect of course not
does biden's
platform on healthcare fix all of the
problems we've identified
not even close but if trump got his way
30 million people would lose coverage
okay let's not miss the forest for the
trees we're going to have
more on this on our instagram account
follow us there at david pakman show
follow me on instagram
david.pakman for pictures from my
vacation
which i will talk about on today's bonus
show